c'est la terreur de l'industrie
forestière qui s'attaque aux conifères
fait apparaître catastrophique
apocalyptique des humains compétitionne
avec l'insecte pour la même ressource
pour le pour le bourg la tordeuse des
bourgeons de l'épinette c'est l'ennemi à
abattre
on devrait pas toujours avoir peur la
tordeuse donc faut pas en faire une
chasse aux sorcières mais pour récupérer
à tout prix le bois affecté le ministère
des forêts des crêtes des plans spéciaux
l'équivalent des mesures de guerre le
fameux article 60
permet à peu près n'importe quoi et
surtout n'oblige pas le ministre
s'expliquer pourquoi il fait ça et ça ça
éveille des soupçons qu'on a toujours
pensé c'est celle d'un prétexte parce
qu'il ya un projet des aires protégées
j'appelle ça de la broye
un lanceur d alerte révèle une entente
secrète qui va encore plus loin sa cote
or la tordeuse a servi par à 20 pour
garder les compagnies forestières en vie
pour bien des québécois l'épidémie de
tordeuses est devenu l'excusent
politiques et économiques parfaite qui
permet à l'état de favoriser l'industrie
une excuse tordu
le soleil se lève sur le lac roger au
témiscamingue depuis 45 ans six familles
se donnent rendez vous ici quelques fois
par année trois générations au profit de
la nature et cumulent des souvenirs
j'ai ici depuis 1976 mes parents m'ont
traîné
sur leur dos a pratiquement danse et al
on venait il y avait aucun chemin danser
à cette époque là on venait on passait
par la rivière des outaouais en faisant
un grand détour montée des rapides
au fil des ans le groupe a construit un
chalet des sentiers et des installations
de chasse à l'orignal qui fait les
convenances pub merci tu as tellement
sauvage belle place le montage est au
paradis paradis de charge à part à 10h
page et paradis de loisirs aussi mais au
printemps dernier leurs retrouvailles
habituels ont pris une autre tournure
c'est déjà dans la tristesse
c'est sans nombre des années et
des années de l'oise est l'auteur d'un
père nations n'ont pas pris son rôle
utile ça sera plus jamais pareil
une grande partie des forêts qu'il
connaît si bien ont été rasés pendant
l'hiver le paysage est défigurée ils ont
perdu leurs repères
je le sais démoralisés c'est vraiment
plutôt pitoyable je m'attendais
définitivement pas à ce genre de
spectacle c'était le plan spécial de
tordeuse des bourgeons de l'épinette
l'urgence est elle là on se pose la
question encore sur ces images captées
duo désert on voit nettement la
différence avant et après les coupes
forestières sur le territoire
ces familles qui avaient réclamé des
coupes partiel pour préserver une partie
des vieilles forêts se sentent floués
oui on sait que l'industrie doit venir à
mon sens d'humour et que c'est ça fait
partie de notre économie mais pas comme
ça pas de cette façon-là
contrairement à ce que son nom indique
la tordeuse se nourrit surtout de sapins
mais le problème nous dit celle qui est
ingénieur forestière depuis 20 ans c'est
qu'ici il n'y en a presque pas on nous
envoyait une faute aucune image où
justement il y avait des sapins guéri
partout c'était vraiment très très
affecté par la tordeuse des bourgeons de
l'épinette mais c'était beau chez nous
c'était pas notre territoire après avoir
le dollar a pu avoir le dos large la
bibitte les experts comme hubert morin
établissent qu'il faut au moins 25% de
sapins dans une forêt pour qu'elle soit
considérée vulnérables à la tordeuse
mais dans l'inventaire estimé du
ministère avant les coupes dans ce
secteur la proportion était d'à peine 15
%
ce chemin par l'unfp 15% de sapins cpo
suffisait mais en supposant que les 15%
de sapin ameur
se soit pas une catastrophe économique
le ministère ici est venu faire une
récolte qui étaient en dehors en fait du
geared habituel du gouvernement au
bénéfice de récolter du bois qui est
beaucoup plus payant pour le titre
faurecia
[Musique]
en arrivant sur le terrain ils ont
constaté que les piles de bio de sapins
coupés et est minuscule par rapport aux
autres essences de bois comme c'est
énorme pile d'épinette noire
l'épinette noire c'est le bois qu'on a
le meilleur en fait en forêt pour qui
comme bois de construction
on s'est vraiment fait avoir la puis les
raisons les motivations pour venir et si
c'est pour le bourg était purement
économique pourquoi se servir de ça
comme prétexte pour faire n'importe quoi
c'est la pire des choses dans une
situation d'urgence
mathieu bouchard travaillé au ministère
des forêts jusqu'à l'an dernier il
enseigne maintenant à l'université laval
et croit que les plans spéciaux sont
justifiés en cas de force majeure mais
pas pour contourner le système il ya
beaucoup de problèmes en fort historique
ont eu tendance à mettre de côté depuis
les dernières années des problèmes
d'acceptabilité sociale ou la tordeuse
un doublage mais c'est aussi beaucoup je
trouve un révélateur de problèmes
latents
pour la majorité des chercheurs le
constat est clair actuellement c'est
plus une question qui est économique et
politique
plus que plus qu'une gestion
scientifique
l'état peut contourner la loi sur
l'aménagement durable des forêts donner
de l'argent à l'industrie et même
dépassé les limites de coupe grâce aux
plans spéciaux tant de pouvoir créer de
la méfiance
[Musique]
des cds groupe
c'est le cas à saguenay où des citoyens
agissent comme des gardiens de la forêt
cyriac il mène un bras de fer politique
pour préserver des bouleaux jaunes gea
au cours des quatre derniers siècles ces
vieux arbres ont été témoins de
l'histoire du québec quand je t'offre
l'appui je me ferme les yeux je pense à
champlain qui étaient ici quand ce
tableau est né moi ce qui m'impressionne
c'est la force de ses tableaux moi
j'espère mourir avant que autres moeurs
depuis 18 ans ils se posent aux coupes
forestières et revendique une aire
protégée au sud du lac kénogami en
portée du touriste ici lol ça va ça va
revenir et bien plus d'argent coupez une
forêt puis après thor faut attendre sans
paix en 2004 des citoyens ont occupé la
forêt et réussi à freiner les abatteuses
quand le ministère des forêts est revenu
à la charge huit ans plus tard ils sont
parvenus à éviter les coupes dès que le
projet leur protégé on commence à se
parler se sont restés y est venu
récolter lucie carrier était alors
l'ingénieur forestière de la ville de
saguenay poste qu'elle a occupé pendant
15 ans quand on négocie avec le mène
l'industrie où le ministère peut importe
c'est toujours la même rengaine pas
touche au mètre cube
pas touche au profit ils nous ont
vraiment dit bah écoutez si vous
récoltez pas de bois on vous retire la
gestion des terres publiques être aux
municipales
en 2014 le projet d'aires protégées a
obtenu l'appui de la ville et un
consensus régional le ministère de
l'environnement avait tout en main pour
préserver le bassin versant du lac
kénogami qui est la principale source
d'eau potable de saguenay est si fort et
rare
ça vaut vraiment la peine de protéger
ces territoires qui sont des belles
forêts mais dès le départ le ministère
des forêts a bloqué le projet raconte
celui qui était chargé du dossier
jusqu'à sa retraite l'an dernier
n'ont jamais été d'accord avec aucun des
projets a fait n'était pas content on
allait faire le travail en janvier 2019
six fonctionnaires du ministère des
forêts sont débarqués à l'hôtel de ville
de saguenay en brandissant le spectre
des pertes d'emplois et l'épidémie de
tordeuses
c'était clair que j'allais pas être en
faveur
des coupes total qui voulait faire à la
fois russe ria
lucie carrier n'a pas été invité à la
rencontre la ville a dit oui aux coupes
pour ne pas perdre de bois le ministère
des forêts a finalement réussi à mettre
la hache dans l'air protéger candidate
avec un plan spécial et le ministère de
l'environnement n'avait pas le pouvoir
de l'arrêter
comme les bananes dans une république de
bananes
on récolte des bananes dont les vins il
y avait beaucoup d'endroits où récolter
la tordeuse ailleurs que dans le projet
terre protégée que besoin d'aller lol on
a voulu connaître les détails de
l'entente signée pour ses coupes entre
le ministère et la ville grâce à la loi
d'accès à l'information
mais les pages importantes ont été
effacés
plus de 200 personnes ont dit non aux
coupes lors des consultations
une représentante de l'industrie leur a
expliqué pourquoi ça ne changeait rien
de quoi aller récolter danse est un
ruisseau sam n'est pas sur la
possibilité forestière et
malheureusement si on évoque la
possibilité d'installer petite souris il
ya un autre moteur malgré une levée de
boucliers de grands pans de forêts ont
été décimées le ministère s'est placé
dans une situation ce qu' il ne peut
plus compter les citoyens au saguenay
lac saint jean le ministère a tellement
accordé deux contrats
d'approvisionnement garantie a tellement
de syrie que les fonctionnaires du
ministère cherche le bourg
andré new york a tenté en vain de faire
annuler ces coupes forestières devant
les tribunaux comme dit l'expression les
dés sont pipés d'avancé les plans sont
en fait et le ministre n'a aucune
intention de tenir compte des résultats
des consultations plus avec les autres
gardiens de la forêt il poursuit la
bataille
voyez pioneer avait été coupé qui avait
pas d'affaires est recoupée
érablière coupé ruisseau affecter les
bénévoles surveille sans relâche les
opérations forestières et déposent des
plaintes au ministère il s'assure que
les abatteuses ne s'approche pas à plus
de 60 mètres des arbres géants en partie
protégé
ses tableaux on leur enlève l'or leur
leurs forêts tout le tour ils vont
mourir simplement
le 7 mars dernier le conseil municipal
de saguenay a demandé la suspension de
toutes nouvelles coupes forestières et
d'accélérer la création de leurs
protégés
[Musique]
on met le cap maintenant sur la côte
nord
c'est la région où l'épidémie de
tordeuses a commencé en 2006
on se dirige vers un secteur difficile
d'accès qui ne risque pas d'être rasé
une vieille forêt où les arbres date des
années 1800 c'est là que des chercheurs
enquête sur les effets de l'insecte
depuis 15 ans
ici loin de démoniser la tordeuse les
experts lève le voile sur son rôle
crucial dans l'écosystème
sais pas ce n'est pas nécessairement une
catastrophe pour la forêt c'est quelque
chose qui a toujours dynamisée ses
forêts d'un point de vue écologique la
tordeuse c-power c'est pur esprit un
problème
la tordeuse existe depuis que les arbres
sont dans le paysage elle fertilise le
sol nourrit les oiseaux et permet à la
forêt et de se régénérer le problème
c'est quand on ne voit que la valeur
économique du bois
moi je suis un utilisateur de la forêt
j'achète du bois jeux conscient qu' on
en a besoin de bois puis je suis
aucunement compte l'industrie forestière
ce que je veux c'est d'utiliser les
connaissances qu'on a pour mieux la
ménager cette forêt
sur la côte-nord la tordeuse et mal
aimée parce que quand l'épidémie a
frappé l'industrie était à l'agonie hees
a amplifié le problème de rentabilité
en quelques années la région était passé
de douze à quatre usines
[Musique]
les coûts des opérations forestières
sont les plus élevés du québec dans
cette région et à cause de la tordeuse
des compagnies ont dû récupérer plus de
sapins qui valent moins cher et ça ne
faisait pas leurs affaires
les compagnies ont fait beaucoup de
pression du gros lobby sous le
gouvernement ce lanceur d' alerte au
sein du gouvernement qui a demandé à ne
pas être identifiée par peur de
représailles rappelle que l'industrie a
fait des mises à pied produits
forestiers résolu et rémabec on menaçait
de fermer leurs installations si le
gouvernement du québec ne donnait pas un
coup de main sur le plan financier
les gens se sont mobilisés pour sauver
les emplois la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'on est parvenu à une entente et
litchi s'engage à reprendre un travail
sur la saône la côte nord cailleux
l'entente avec le gouvernement
industrie tu es sur le respirateur
artificiel ça lui a donné des avantages
à
cette entente signée en 2015 avec les
trois compagnies forestières de la
côte-nord a été en vigueur jusqu'à
l'automne 2021
attend d'eux a servi à ça c'est un
prétexte pour financer l'industrie
l'état vend le bois arabe et pour
conserver des emplois ça vaut toujours
coûté plus cher qu'ailleurs sur la côte
membres sans gouvernement c'est pas
rentable sauf quand le prix du bois
d'oeuvre est très élevé
québec un refusé de nous remettre une
copie de l'entente en vertu de la loi
d'accès à l'information en évoquant des
secrets industriels et un possible
problème diplomatique
de tout contexte de dire comment on fait
pour aider l'industrie ce sont les
américains disent qu'on finance mais
nous avons réussi à l'obtenir de sources
confidentielles
notre lanceur d'alert estime que les
québécois ont payé cher pour favoriser
l'industrie et permettre aux compagnies
forestières de satisfaire leurs
actionnaires tout en amputant la forêt
du futur c'est pas la bonne façon de
gérer la forêt c'est ça qui me choque la
proximité avec les industries est
malsaine rabais sur le bois coupé dans
les forêts publiques exemption de
paiement de la moitié de la redevance
annuelle aide financière pour chaque
hectare récolté allègement des prêts du
gouvernement
avec l'entente québec a fait cadeau d'au
moins 20 millions de dollars à
l'industrie pour garder les usines
ouvertes mais ça n'a pas empêché des
pertes d'emplois et à cet argent
s'ajoute l'aide financière des plans
spéciaux pour la tordeuse dont québec
n'a pas divulgué le montant total les
volumes de bois garantit aux compagnies
sont subventionnés dès qu'il ya 15% de
sapins c'est comme financer des coupes
normal c'est pas beaucoup caisse pour ça
dans les deux dernières années alors que
les deux par quatre étaient vendus à des
prix records aux consommateurs
l'industrie recevait des millions en
aide financière pour couper ce bois et
ses forêts là appartiennent aux
québécois l'aide financière s'est jamais
assez ce pas normal que ça prenne aux
stratagèmes pour garder des emplois avec
la bénédiction du gouvernement si les
compagnies renonce aux volumes de bois
garantis par l'état au tarif en vigueur
ces volumes sont mis aux enchères à un
prix minimum et la plupart du temps
c'est la compagnie qui s'est désisté qui
rachète le même bois à une fraction du
prix initial parce qu'elle est la seule
à enchérir en tarification en vigueur et
le prix payé pour le lot il ya un
méchant octobre c'est un système connu
sa côte nord de copinage pour payer le
moins possible le ton ce mécanisme prévu
dans l'entente est parfaitement légal
mais selon le lanceur d'alerté d'autres
sources c'est loin d'être moral on a
analysé les chiffres de lourds annoncés
par l'industrie mis aux enchères il
valait 21 millions de dollars ils ont
été vendus 9 millions et demi
le ministère nous a fourni des chiffres
similaires c'est beaucoup d'argent tenet
beaux prix minimum
[Musique]
c'est une aubaine
l'industrie a obtenu plus de 50% de
rabais sur 80 mille camions remplis de
bois et ironiquement alors qu'elle
devait récupérer le bois à risque à
cause de la tordeuse il s'est coupé
quatre fois plus des pinèdes scène que
de sa pince infesté sur certains
chantiers y ont laissé des gros lots de
sapins ils ont écrit mais la forêt pour
ramasser tout l'épinette
sarah la forêt plus vulnérables à la
prochaine épidémie l'important c'est les
profits maintenant le ministre des
forêts pierre dufour n'a pas répondu à
nos questions mais dans une déclaration
écrite son cabinet dit prioriser les
coupes dans les forêts sévèrement
atteintes par la tordeuse des forêts
condamné l'industrie forestière elle
considère que québec a réagi trop tard
pour combattre l'épidémie eq c'était la
moindre des choses de la compenser pour
les énormes pertes
la situation s'est constamment sans une
forêt qui ont manqué d'amour humble qui
ont un potentiel de transformation qui
est moins sauf que la réalité c'est
récolté 1 hectare cottin pie x les
tordeuses ou pas l'industrie déplore le
manque de budget pour reboiser les
forêts de la côte nord
c'est la volonté de l'état de faire
comme ça mais c'est une volonté qui
n'ont pas ou qui n'ont pas de vision sur
le très long terme
les scientifiques qui poursuivent leurs
recherches sur la tordeuse se désole
aussi du manque de vision parce que les
épidémies sont prévisibles et reviennent
environ tous les 30 ans elle a toujours
été là la tour 2 va probablement
toujours être le on pourrait peut-être
aménager les forêts pour les rendre
moins vulnérables à long terme mais ce
poste par la direction qu'on consent
logique et on est loin d'être sorti du
bois on apprend qu'il existe une entente
similaire avec l'industrie en
abitibi-témiscamingue sur la côte nord
une nouvelle entente de cinq ans vient
d'être signée en évoquant la tordeuse
mais la récolte de sapins est maintenant
optionnel et on continue de vendre nous
faut république à prix réduit
[Musique]